[Music]
welcome to the show
[Music]
came a long way from the basement now
I'm a father like Kevin and Jason life
is amazing when it comes to your family
everything really come down to
communication all in your head about it
but don't forget about it just let it
out let's talk it out let's talk it out
let's talk it out let's talk it out
sit down
sit your ass down let's talk it out
hey boy you better are y'all tuning in
right now yeah yeah Happy Father's Day
with Jay and Silent Bob man I'm Kevin
Smith Jason Muse oh yeah we're back kids
back to talk about
be in death making dad jokes being
[ __ ] because that's what dads
are literal definition we should have
knew some good actual dad jokes all you
tell are dad jokes now do I yeah even
what was the edge back in the day like
Hey kid snooch to the news now it's just
baby talk for [ __ ] children
I got a joke it's Dad jokes to the news
you gotta come up here because it comes
with a different yes it does indentation
no
intonation yeah yeah intention yeah so
you think
um uh welcome back it's episode two
of Father's Day last episode
uh uh numbnuts over here revealed at the
very end that he's still fertile as [ __ ]
and flat out impregnated a woman yeah
the Miracle of Life kids
[ __ ] produced by
adjacent Muse simply because he was too
lazy to pull out no you actually were
planning for this we were we were
planning okay so we uh that's funny you
say I actually feel like my pull out
move worked really well for a long time
but
um well in the Father's Day podcast
where we tell you how to not be a father
here's my pull out method it worked for
years and I know it doesn't always but
um no we did plan and it's great like
she uh you know she started she even
went out and bought this and I wish I
had more descriptions because this is
where I'm like check it out get a code
for it now
um but there's it's a bracelet that I
guess like keeps track of your cycle and
such like that right she also took out
like uh packages to piano stick and it
says when your your business like you're
more fertile than other days and and
there would be days where it's like hey
today I'm fertile and even if like I was
leaving or that she we would you know
get in a [ __ ] beds and not even like
just make a deposit must go she's like
look I pissed on a stick now put your
[ __ ] dick in me and make life you
ain't gonna make me come but just
deposit now no probably we've never uh
when Jen and I had Harley it was a total
uh
uh well my pull out method was not
nearly as proven as yours apparently
because Harley exists but there was uh
you know no hey let's have a baby yeah
no it just happened and it worked out
very well was every one second where
you're like to see my kid did you go to
that that like denial phase where you're
like [ __ ] never and especially the
moment she came out the moment she came
out well of course yeah
I took her out her word I mean why you
know she had traveled all the way to
[ __ ] New Jersey yeah yeah it's crazy
because that happens to people but I
didn't pick it up I just didn't know if
you had even one second when you're like
wait a second what would be crazy about
it is if it turned like because Harley
literally looks like as Jen says
beardless [ __ ] me yeah but that
would be really weird is that we took a
blood test and found out we were not
related just by chance that we kind of
looked alive yeah yeah oh my gosh and
Jen was like I was keeping it on the
download last time I'm like oh my God
how would I feel would I would I be like
like I hear I know this about myself to
some degree I can't speak to this weird
[ __ ] case with the kid if it was you
know real but
I remember when my mother told me she
was adopted
and that changed how I looked at all my
relatives because I was like I'm not
related to these [ __ ] I don't share
blood with these people blood is a big
thing with me because my father and
mother the worst argument I ever seen my
parents get in
my my mom
was Christmas and uh we were young I was
like six seven or eight or something
like that and Michael Wayne you know the
guy in clerks three like look at this
[ __ ] guy yeah yeah he ain't even
looking gee whiz does Michael Wayne
um he was coming he called my my house
like Christmas night of Christmas like
six seven o'clock
and he was like oh I'm gonna stop by my
dad was like oh great and then my mom
was like what are you letting him stop
by for like everyone's in pajamas like
the night's over Christmas is done and
he's like well he's in the area stop by
and my mom
was pointing out to my dad some [ __ ]
that like my uncle had done in the past
and [ __ ] where she [ __ ] him over and
whatnot
try to Aid her argument yeah yeah and my
father who like never [ __ ] got in my
mom's Grill he was whiny and she like
Christ but he was never like you listen
here Grace like she was the [ __ ]
pants wearing [ __ ]
but I'll never forget in his voice he
goes blood is thicker than water Grace
yeah and I had no idea what that meant I
found out later on what it meant yeah
yeah but my mom knew what it meant her
face [ __ ] lit the [ __ ] up dude I've
never seen her more Angry in my life she
stormed out of the room two seconds
after she left the living room and she
you know how small my house on 21
Jackson Street was
two seconds three seconds after she
walked out of the [ __ ] living room
Wham
and everybody just [ __ ] look the
whole house shook
and my brother after a few seconds he's
like
and I went and looked and right outside
my bedroom door but the bedroom door the
bedroom me and my brother shared
my mom had come around the corner and
[ __ ] right hooked into the wall so
hard that she [ __ ] broke the wall wow
and they kept it like that dude for
until the flood until the Nor'easter so
I would say honestly that was
15 years of my life that hole was in the
wall is constant reminder of like don't
you ever [ __ ] say blood is thicker
than water but
blood is thicker than water yeah like
think about it like you my blood my
blood tie is too hard Harley is the only
person in this house that I'm directly
blood tied to Jennifer I choose
her parents I choose but we're not
related and sure
in your house Logan's the only one that
you're blood relative to yeah but that's
where the unconditional love comes from
right like but what happens is I did
this to Harley on vegan Aptoide years
ago what happens when the aliens come
and they're like you can only choose one
do you choose the blood
or do you choose the choice do you
choose Jordan or choose Logan well that
doesn't even take into what you got to
choose only one because they're like
we're gonna vaporize the other no well
it's not they're not going to vaporize
no they are that's the [ __ ] deal you
can't change it can't can't they say
that they're like hey the world's gonna
end they could but they're not excited
with us you can come with us they're not
saying that they're ain't nice they're
[ __ ] evil dude all right so and
they're like they're evil but at the
same time they're like we're giving you
one we could just [ __ ] Slaughter
everybody so you guys no there's no
question I would pick uh Logan for sure
how do you think Jordan feels about that
she knows you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] well
if you both choose Logan then we both
get killed did you no
um blood is a big [ __ ] thing and
right now your blood is coursing through
your [ __ ] wife's body in a little
human being now
do you know what that human being is
last time we didn't even [ __ ] know I
do I do so we found out oh this is big
news right yeah it's a boy you're gonna
have a [ __ ] little boy yes oh my god
um ladies lock up your daughters ladies
lock up your sons you don't know it
could be [ __ ] totally it's uh it
could be pansexual he's like I [ __ ] it
all dad but I don't give a [ __ ] by then
there might be new names I know right
like [ __ ] he's like I'm Omni
galactosexual and you're like what's
that he's like I [ __ ] the universe don't
you limit me [ __ ] it's uh it
honestly it is exciting it's uh exciting
because we wanted you know the wife and
I both were like you know of course it'd
be nice to have either or just I wanted
a matching set yeah but the American
family mom dad son daughter son yeah and
it's great and right now it's farmer
dogs going through names Grandma yeah
the whole the whole works the whole day
you have the look what we need is the
wife yeah it's true
um and you just bought a new house we
did we did which could you could
literally put a white picket fence
around that house and it it would look
[ __ ] Suburban picturesque like the
American dream this
is what uh needs be pointed out as you
uh uh head into
um
fatherhood
a second time
um you have everything you ever wanted
when you were a kid you would always be
like you know I want what you got yeah
and I was like what a huge [ __ ] [ __ ]
and you were like no man I want like
like a wife and a kid family and a house
and [ __ ] like that and back then it was
it like nearly impossible for you to put
together it was anathema yeah I might as
well have been like we'll figure out how
to get to Mars same [ __ ] diff but now
you're living
in your [ __ ] dream like you're
literally your dream has come true you
made your dream come true you have a
wife you have not just one kid but a
[ __ ] second kid on the way you have
the family that you always crave you
have a home like you literally [ __ ]
have it all it's yeah it's well I almost
say I have it all but what are you what
are you missing I I just feel like
having it all I guess for the most part
yes yeah but what you don't have a jet
like no he's an athletic don't have it
well I'm saying you're right I mean
material things there could be more but
I guess I do have everything a lovely
wife uh and uh family a house a car I
even have my favorite car so I do for
the most part I literally have it all it
is but I don't like this it sounds
no it's it's not you're not hey you
didn't say it I didn't but B turn your
mic away from the door a little bit no
you don't have to close it just turn the
mic it's pointed directly yeah yeah it
definitely it definitely uh and now tilt
the mic down because it's pointing at
your eyes it definitely being a [ __ ]
dad the second time has not improved
your podcasting skills don't you [ __ ]
I don't have a headset I didn't know
that was that one don't you twitch all
the time I stream all the time but my
thing's on the table and it's
multi-directional oh it's better well
well it can be it's not better this is a
great mic I have one of these too but I
realized I would do this a lot when I
was streaming especially just to test
guys you're gonna hear a weird noise but
if I was playing a game and I was
streaming like this not so bad right a
minute oh my God
[Music]
all right so
um you had a story before we started
you're like yeah yes again because it
has to do with the father but really
quick I I feel like I don't wanna the
fun thing is and maybe this is something
we can do because mentioning that I have
everything and I do want to say this and
I'm not just saying it because we're on
a podcast but I feel like it's a big
um
a big
loss of words but I feel like the
podcast is a big stepping stone or uh
road to what I have now because I was
doing the podcast to get old podcast so
it was a big deal and what I think is
great is I'm hoping that people enjoy
this podcast because I do feel like it's
the next chapter and and it's part of
everything all this time leading up to
that I didn't have a house while we were
doing the podcast I got a house then I
had a kid and then I got so it would be
awesome to go further with this because
it is Father for me being a father and
being able to talk about it is crazy
because for example tonight on the way
here I had a call one of the parents and
I don't want to say that's why I was
like oh I don't know if I should tell
the story because I would hate for a
parent to hear this knowing it's them
and be like well you shouldn't have told
that story but you keep it there [ __ ]
but I'll vague I try to be big is is so
we got a call and I'm like oh my gosh
what happened what did my daughter do to
this other girl and this boy and all
that and what it was we found out that
my daughter instigated one of the boys
last year had a crush on one of the
seven six-year-old girls and that isn't
the kid she didn't feel the same way
right
um and this year it's sort of been okay
there's been no really no trouble with
it but I guess there's still some
um feelings in the back so my daughter
came up with the idea or we don't know
if it was my daughter it was one of the
two or three girls she was with for
those who were like what is your
daughter that Logan is a Jay's
seven-year-old daughter correct so she's
in my second grade yeah second grade
these are all second graders and these
three second grade girls wrote a letter
saying hey this person likes you the
girl that liked the boy the boy the girl
the boy liked last year they said this
girl likes you she has a crush on you
and gave the boy the letter after the
boy read it and was like oh wow okay
like I guess right after I was like she
just kidding we wrote that no she
doesn't and he got really upset and a
bunch of the other kids heard and they
were teasing him and he got really
heartbroken and went home and told his
dad and was sad and all this stuff right
and again it was it was one of those
things where when I got to call him like
I know it wasn't a malicious thing I
know they weren't like watched let's
crush this kid's dreams they were like
this is funny you know uh so and so
kissing in a tree okay like the
goofiness but it really hurt the boy's
feeling so now I gotta tell you like
you've got to please apologize you hurt
his feelings
um but it's that weird thing where I'm
like oh what a big baby who cares like
part of me feels that way but I know
like that isn't the case and this is
where well maybe your kids should
toughen the [ __ ] up yeah his wife is
hard and that's how I feel partially but
I don't feel that way but I think that
at first but again this is where I'm
like am I a bad father for thinking that
like you know should I tell her to
apologize or no she shouldn't have to
apologize because she was just playing
around having fun it's like well my
advice yeah sure as a veteran and the
father yes please got a 23 year old um I
wouldn't uh
I wouldn't have encountered this my
kid's super you know super [ __ ]
empathetic super soft and [ __ ]
um but if I'm you
I'm part to her how maybe she didn't
mean this but like that hurt yeah yeah
boy and stuff and like how would she
feel
if she was the one that everybody was
told from that and stuff you got to
create empathy uh in the kid
um you know so that it don't ever happen
again because
she's adorable and you don't you know
she'll
pretty people get away with a lot in
life and
you know she will probably get away with
a lot you might want to early on yeah
yeah make sure she knows that makes
sense put somebody else's feelings think
about somebody else's don't put them
before your own but think about somebody
else's feelings and always cast yourself
in the role of like what if that was me
what if everyone in class what if I got
that note yes and then I was like oh I
like that boy because I know she's like
the older boy and [ __ ] like that use
that example like remember that older
boy what a [ __ ] everyone wrote a note
to him
and or you about him and then they were
like just kidding and then they were
amazing totally it makes yeah so then
yeah it'll be easier for her to get her
head around it because you're right she
probably didn't do it going like let's
shatter this [ __ ] yeah no no I want
to break a man at seven exactly and then
for a second I'm like well maybe you
should my kids like you can break a man
at seven you can break a man at nine and
nine years old I went to the water slide
Long Branch remember the ones
I went to the Long Branch water slide
and uh you know I'm going up and down
having a [ __ ] time of my life man
like I was a big water slide [ __ ] fan
oh yeah ain't nothing sad about a water
slides Good Times
until there's always some [ __ ] that
sits at the top who's like wait go yeah
wait go
so I've been up and down four times and
[ __ ]
get to the top for the fifth time and
[ __ ] and the guy goes whoa whoa whoa
pregnant ladies can't ride the slide oh
[ __ ] oh bro I went down so sad
yeah there were more of my Tears in that
water slide than the actual water itself
and
I'm 52. yeah and I could still see it
vividly and yeah yeah it I can't die of
my entire [ __ ] life this offhanded
comment by some [ __ ] and it could
have been worse like imagine if it was
like at the pool and there was a bunch
of people around and they're like yeah
yeah
and I'm like no
how can I be pregnant I'm getting my
period it is uh it's crazy because again
these
situations dude think about how cool
kids were when we were kids oh it's yeah
now kids are so much more sophisticated
like yeah it'd be it'd be tough to be a
kid right now like when we were kids
like think about it biggest thing you
had to worry about was like you know oh
my god get a valentine yeah yeah oh like
can I go trick-or-treating oh what will
I get for Christmas and [ __ ]
now kids got to deal with like I mean I
guess we had to deal with a looming
threat of nuclear war no yeah there is a
lot of stuff and there's I feel like for
now for me it's seems like more people
are aware of things because of the cell
phone
yeah and all that stuff but I also like
Wonder this is a big thing our next
question is I was thinking about I I
talked about this to to Jordan
um again I don't want to say a person's
name but I remember we had to take uh
showers and after gym class yeah I knew
it was probably I think there's about 20
of us that were in the class that say
boys anyway Henry Hudson Regional yeah
and you had to shower out of 20 boys
there was only one boy not circumcised
yeah he had a hooded monster and we
would sort of tease him a little bit
that's his name yeah yeah and so we
would somewhat not tease them but like
people would make yours is different
yeah and and so but I but now it's like
that's where your kid gets it I don't
know
like pregnant lady pregnant but it seems
it so the question on the floor is do we
get do we you're having a boy yes do
does the boy get circumcised totally now
Jason and I are of a circumcised
generation so our dicks look like what
we would consider normal
however
that was a thing of like the 70s I
believe 70s and early 80s where they
were just [ __ ] you know this used to
be a a Jewish practice Yeah Moyle would
come in and circumcise where it comes
from
then I guess they adopted it as as like
well this will help with uh cleanliness
and godliness I guess so that you know
it became prevalent but then like after
our generation I guess people started
being like that's [ __ ] weird and they
started letting boys have sleeves again
yeah my old man was uncut oh really yeah
did you see his mom my whole [ __ ]
life he was always like look at it ain't
it weird it don't look like yours do it
I'm like sure don't do it can you put it
away
yeah look at this wizard sleeve you want
to see a surprise no Goose coming out
it's been so fast
look at the balrog here he is
now he goes back in the game
I do Wonder though I want to ask I never
saw here that's such a weird thing I
mean I guess this is something that most
most children would be proud to Proclaim
but like I've I never saw my dad's dick
head all I saw was the [ __ ] sleeve so
I don't even know if he's got a mushroom
cap or nothing yeah my whole life I
think those little piss climbs
[Laughter]
20 years is it okay to ask my mom like
so what happened when you roll that [ __ ]
back what was under there magic she was
like oh it was luscious magic well
that's why I want to ask an adult like
when when it rolls back you could have
asked him okay why didn't you [ __ ]
thing to ask my dad when he was around
in the future Mr Smith could have
decision can I ask you a question about
your dick well think about it he must
have cleaned that [ __ ] all the time
because it's like it's just attracting
like Wells or is it you know what I'm
saying like Eric clips
[Laughter]
you know the Crocs have little [ __ ]
jibs or whatever you get little dick
gems
I was like what's this drawbridge
training he's like that's to hold my
[ __ ] dick in
I don't know if it's any less like
sanitary like they I think you're
thinking like all the [ __ ] gets in there
but I think it stays covered no until
it's time I feel like I know when I when
it gets hard that's when the [ __ ]
head pops up yeah and it comes out
it was a [ __ ] T2 enchantment
oh no there's something under there it's
gonna explode
um yeah I don't know dude let's think
about it I the most experience I have
with a dick all the experience I have to
take is my own so I know it looks one
way I saw my dad's dick by virtue of the
fact of my because I'm sure some people
out there it's like can you go back to
how you know what your dad's dick looks
like my parents would walk around naked
all the time that's awesome not like you
know nudists but like they go from their
bedroom out of their bedroom to the
bathroom yeah and never put on robes or
anything like that she just did son I
sure do dad all right then
he's not your brothers and sisters
damn skippy you did you lived in my nuts
now you live in my house
um but I don't I don't I can't say for
certain how it works but I think
that it's you know that [ __ ] gets in
there that like that it's I think that
it comes out and then goes in I think
the only time [ __ ] would get in is when
you're [ __ ]
I I mean I like when you're it's crazy
that like we're 52 you're 48 and like
we've never talked to somebody yeah I'm
gonna talk to I know someone who has but
I'm gonna ask him I don't know if I
could say but don't say that but I I do
know who's got her yeah I want to ask
him though like does it get thicker when
it pulls back because you think all that
extra [ __ ] meat right pulls back down
and [ __ ] it's like a scarf God it's like
a scarf and [ __ ] it's Gotta look more
impressive uh what you're losing in you
know familiarity and as much as like
most people think of a dick looking like
oh it's got the little [ __ ] mushroom
cap and [ __ ] like that
but you lose in the familiarity
you gain in the surprise like the show
of it all because it's always like it
now ladies and gentlemen for your
viewing pleasure because he's going to
come out right
back it's like coming up the stages that
elevate Liberace
um yeah so will so the big question is
then do we do it yeah well is it better
for him as a as a boy will he care when
he's older
no not at all it just seems so normal to
me I know that's what I mean that was
the way we was raised but now think
about it
now really think about the process
what the [ __ ] is normal about it yeah
like them taking the little boy little
babies
but no good [ __ ] this kid's gonna
enter the world and [ __ ] like life
Life's good and all of a sudden
somebody's like give me your dick yeah
you're cutting at it and [ __ ] oh that's
trauma and if they [ __ ] it up and it
could like just have like a little yeah
I don't know if I were if I had had a
kid who was a boy
I don't think I would have done it yeah
yeah it don't it'll be interesting we
were still talking about it that and the
names are the big thing so you know
we're thinking of names which I would
love to get feedback uh I don't know if
we're gonna have a way to get comments
and such for this but if there is yeah
hopefully all this we have this uh
you're gonna put it under hashtag
uh uh Father's Day jsb yes on Father's
Day JSP give us suggestions or no
hashtag
baby boy Muse yes
b-a-b-y-b-o-y-m-e-w-s hashtag baby boy
Muse drop us your suggestion so the last
name is Muse yeah not Monsanto muse no
me is so just flat out Muse yeah
um
we've been talking Jay and I about
alliterative names yeah uh do you want
to tell them the name of you I'm afraid
like do is there someone that like from
now to when our kids born here's this
and then names their son what the good
good thought don't don't share it so if
you're not you Jay has a favorite which
I will say
is pretty [ __ ] amazing pretty metal
yeah I like it yeah I'd go for it 100
Jordan's like Jordan has is hesitant
which again it was such a dip when we
had Logan we knew boy or girl we knew we
were having uh the kid's name was Jimmy
Logan which was so easy like right her
and I agreed on it we we didn't even
have to go well how about maybe it was
like Logan that's it it was the way it
was with Harley it was always Harley
Quinn but there was a boy it would have
been Charlie Quinn yeah so it's it's um
you know but but we have a bunch of
names we've come up with one of them
I'll say that I like but I know she's
not gonna go for she doesn't want to do
it was asriel I really liked but again I
get why she doesn't want to go with that
and that will be one that we're not
gonna have so I don't mind saying that
one because if someone names our kid
asriel you know but what we noticed is
is Logan goes to school
um our daughter Logan goes to school
with a bunch of kids that have pretty
cool names one of them like we liked was
Roman Rome
um Lucian Lucian was a really other one
we really liked Lucian those are two
names that are currently on
streaming like on streaming services
Roman is in in succession okay yeah he's
a character in succession and Lucian is
the
librarian in um
Sandman oh wow yeah yeah very how Wild
that people are like yeah I'm gonna go
with Lucian a great [ __ ] name we live
in that world you and I grew up in an
age of like Scott yeah Mike John Chris
hung out with us all that standard ass
[ __ ] names man remember Albion Olsen
total like California vibe in New Jersey
but I always thought Albion was a great
[ __ ] yeah yeah and he was unique there
wasn't many there wasn't many names like
[ __ ] no it was a pretty standard ass
selection [ __ ] 70s 80s Ethan like all
those normal names
um so we should open it up to everyone
baby hashtag baby boy Muse
give us some first names yeah let's do
it let's do it that'll be fun I would
love to sit get your feedback and again
of course as you can hear we definitely
know know uh like Jeff's or bills yeah
leave all the [ __ ] standards [ __ ]
and again there's cool names but if I
would love to go as rare as Pop like
rare but it's cool like
um and again I know that not it's really
hard to find a name that hasn't been
taken somewhere but I'm just saying it's
possible comic book
um
comic book origin names also good
considering you got Logan I like to Ryan
but you know Orion is a combo character
yeah yeah Ryan but also many other many
other things not just comic books yeah
of course yeah uh you're thinking of the
new Gods Jack Kirby's New Gods yes oh
Kirby
[Music]
ready yes
Stan Lee Muse oh [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying I yeah yeah so we have to give
the the backstory of the lead right yeah
because isn't Jordan's yeah yeah yes no
so Leah's is uh lee is part of uh
Jordan's her grand great grandmother her
grandmother her mother
um all her middle name is Lee like AJ
yeah like Adrian Lee
um Jordan Lee Jordan Lee Logan Lee
Logan's Logan's middle name's Liz that's
right you're right so the boys don't
have to be but they can be good and
should like I guess they they still live
in the whole world would write about you
naming your kids
I love it I love it do you feel like
it's just someone get offended by that
though there's only one stand no way
that's an honorific bro yeah people name
their kids Dante and Brody for Christmas
and I've met him they're all grown own
up now I've had a 20 year old Brody the
other day man he's like my dad named me
I was like he said well why or I.E
because some Jaws I think it's why he's
like I.E my small rats and I'm like wow
nice I'm your [ __ ] Faja my Brody man
Gucci ninjas
I uh it's it's exciting it's and again
the cool thing is we get to so many big
questions yeah what do you name them do
you cut his dick with a knife the moment
he's born yes and again the cool thing
is we get to talk we're at
um everyone we are at uh next week we go
do uh the full scan I forget what it's
called exactly but we're going to the
doctors to get the full scan uh of
Jordan's the the belly and then we'll
get to see like a 3D image of the baby
um which is awesome again it's and again
I could share that when I am back here
again for the next episode unless we do
one before that but uh regardless one of
the episodes we get to talk about that
and then we get to talk about it the
whole thing maybe we can we can be in
the [ __ ] delivery room with our
Mike's doing the podcast like we just
bring this whole live live podcast
that'd be so like weird considering how
closed captioning not available
[Music]
just [ __ ] job of the Hutt man I gave
up any sense of authority power because
she was like I I take orders from that
no way I don't think she was she dead
bro you don't have to lie I know
sometimes you're laying in bed at night
and she's like he just kept undulating
there were so many roles no no she I
honest to goodness I will tell you right
now because I feel like it would be
something to talk about
you should never mentioned if she did
see you at your shirt off she'd never
said anything to me she's gonna mention
to you on her deathbed as she passes
this world she's been like sir I never
told you yes
sorry attack he was so fat
I feel like I can't believe that's the
last thing she said to me
um
the uh I uh you know what I did today I
mean this is
I don't know if this has much to do with
[ __ ] being a dad but I am a dad so
everything I say yeah being a dad
Harley's dad
um well I guess it does has to do with
Harley so like a year ago
Harley's doctor put her on this shot
and
it was a pre-diabetic shot because
Harley had this weird
chemistry thing that was kind of she was
working out bro like
three times a week the other day she was
like
I did the math
on how much I spent on a personal
trainer
um
um last year because now she works up
she just don't use the person yeah yeah
and I was like and and she was like it
was like way too much and she told me
the figure I ain't gonna share it but
it's it was yeah [ __ ] high and the
whole time she was doing it she like her
body shape wouldn't change even if she
reduced her diet like she was just the
weight wouldn't leave
so the doctor was like you know your
Chemistry that she has a name for a
condition that she has and
he was like they found that this shot is
good for it so she started taking this
shot
and like her it
it suppressed her appetite
and weight started dropping off so
Harley looks [ __ ] amazing like no
she's ever looked in her life yeah yeah
um healthy [ __ ] but like completely
just
like you know [ __ ] she fights my
genetics so you know chub always wants
to move in but she looks phenomenal so
you know I kept telling her for like
months I'm like God damn it kiddo like
you look [ __ ] great man like this is
the best you [ __ ] ever look like what
are you doing
I said wait I want to go what where is
this person like one time I started
working out the person she worked out oh
yeah and I threw up because it was so
[ __ ] hard and [ __ ] I was like no
thank you I don't want this ain't worth
it yeah but she told me about this shot
and she was like I want you to get
um the shot I want you to do this too
and I was like oh I don't know about
that and she's like it's good for heart
attack people and I was like well that
sounds like [ __ ] and she's like
seriously I'll go to your doctor with
you so she went with me to see ladenheim
last time I went Dr Laden my
cardiologist guy saved my life
and uh he was like yeah no I know what
the shot is and it is actually like good
for people like you so he's like you
know I'm I'm not gonna put you on the
one she's on he's gone but there's a
newer one
that's even better and it you know it's
it's not like guaranteed to but
usually you drop about 20 of your body
weight
so it's an injectable pen
and it's called mine is called Manjaro
and you stick it like in your stomach
and you unlock it and you press the
trigger and it goes
and then retracts the needle and [ __ ]
it's pretty amazing and so I've been on
it now for I guess three months or
whatever
and you know I was always like
[ __ ] I'm gonna fast for like 12 days
yeah I remember
now I just don't you know with the tour
I'm preoccupied so I don't really think
about eating as much and blah blah
but between the shot and like I'm hiking
every day like I was leaving on the road
I've been walking four miles a day and
stuff tomorrow morning I like Runyon
um this was the first time I was home in
a month
so you know I was like let me see if my
[ __ ] jacket fits I got this jacket
that's uh Hugo Boss jacket
um that I got in 1998 while we were
making Dogma I wore it to the spirit
awards won a spirit award in that jacket
[ __ ] had made out with and had sex
with schwalbach yeah in that jacket for
the first time and stuff
then uh years later like I wore that
jacket you know after I lost a bunch of
weight after the heart attack I pulled
it out of mothballs and I was like holy
[ __ ] I fit into this [ __ ] jacket that
I fit into when we were making [ __ ]
Dogma that was nuts and so I wore it to
when we got our hands and feet no cement
to the Chinese so that's my Hugo Boss
jacket
um then we went out on tour then for
reboot Road Show then pandemic happened
and I ain't fitting that jacket ever
since yeah you put it on and [ __ ]
looks like Oliver Hardy and [ __ ] like
that of Laurel and Hardy
um but when I came home for the first
time in a [ __ ] month because I left
on September 3rd to start the reboot
Road Show tour
um the convenience store yeah
um I came home today and I put on the
jacket
and not only does it fit but there's
[ __ ] room
so I was like well [ __ ] let me weigh
myself because I ain't done that in a
dog's age
and I know some people have been like
that don't sound [ __ ] thin but
I'm I'm back to the weight I was when I
was at the Chinese Theater if not a
little under I'm 200 pounds nice nice
which for me is [ __ ] great yeah it is
I got full of like loot I'm full of
loose skin because you know when you get
fat pushes your skin out and stuff and
then when you
it retract your stomach gets smaller the
skin just droops it doesn't go back skin
being a big organ you just distend it
and [ __ ] like that so Ethan had that as
well Ethan's plea he had the surgery
where you go in and have all the loose
skin taken off and they literally just
pull it chop it and sew you up no way I
was wondering about that he said and he
suggested never doing it he was like bro
it was the worst recovery he was like it
was so [ __ ] painful like still he's
like I would he's never do it he's gone
it's not worth it
but if I did it
that would easily be about 15 pounds in
just skin but he's literally they're
saying that's the only way to get rid of
the skin there's no other Alternatives
they haven't come up with like when
people build muscle though what does the
muscle pull the nope no because Ethan
yeah yeah no I know he's [ __ ] muscle
no I know he has but still he had she
sent me pictures of like
him jacked oh welcome loose skin I
didn't know I thought he got it no no he
I think he got jacked [ __ ] person
okay okay
um
[Music]
um
there are some cases because I know
people like no it goes back you know
let's say your [ __ ] is like you
let's say you like put on 30 pounds and
[ __ ] and you had like a big old dad got
and [ __ ] and then you like maybe two
years later lost that 30 pounds your
debt and you went back to looking like
you look now you wouldn't have that
distended skin you would you know maybe
you have some stretch mark or two but
like your skin would probably go back to
the way it is now but mine was like yeah
at one point I weighed 330 [ __ ]
pounds and sure that just pushes that
[ __ ] all the [ __ ] out yeah so when your
guts shrink if you're you know you lose
weight the skin doesn't and it just
droops down and [ __ ] so if you look at
me naked
like I look like [ __ ] uh the old lady
in The Shining when she gets out of the
tub first she's a sexy woman and Chip
yeah
or the dude in [ __ ] RoboCop
he gets hit by a car
um so yeah man for anybody like I this
is certainly not a commercial but like
this is actually a [ __ ] thing and I
think it works with insurance
yeah very cool yeah and it doesn't hurt
which is good not at all nothing about
it and once again to bring us back to
fatherhood without my kid and the good
thing is too is
because you're taking that you're saying
when you're not been fasting as much
because you can yeah you're busy of
course but you're eat a little bit on
the road on tour you just but you're not
fasting for five to ten days because
you're taking the show the thing is I
just stop eating which is that's not
normal for me once I start yes I'm like
well I'm gonna get some of this now I'm
gonna go fast
I'm gonna do this and I just like I'll
graze I'll lay on the bed watch a
two-hour movie and consistently eat
throughout not like oh and a bag of
chips I got a bag of chips and then I
had a [ __ ] sandwich and I had my
[ __ ] steak slices then I had pretzels
then I had ice cream then I had [ __ ]
like the two hours of eating yeah
without thinking about like you were
full
an hour and 55 minutes I do it sometimes
yeah so it's you know it helps being on
tour because every night I'm busy yeah
watching the movie every night I have to
stand in front of like a thousand
fifteen hundred people so I'm like well
I don't want to look [ __ ] my worst
I'm gonna look my best
um throw in the shot throw in the
constantly walking yeah that's awesome
it's a good like this gets me exactly
back to where I was when we were
starting reboot Roadshow tour and stuff
and I didn't know that I could get back
there at this point because I was like
oh you know I figured all right well
you'll be like 220 to 2 30 for the rest
of your life or something like that but
now I'm like oh maybe I can keep it
under [ __ ] 200 and [ __ ] 200 or under
that'd be kind of amazing
um
Better Living Through science kids
I like it I like it super super soldier
serum I'm like [ __ ] that'd be awesome
I'm like Steve Rogers
what if I I'm like a very flabby Steve
Rogers they gave you a b complex shot
and they didn't realize the mixture of
that and that they never tried it and
all of a sudden you were like
and all sudden you started hiking and
running [ __ ] professionally like holy
[ __ ] I want I think after the tour I've
always threatened this but like after I
might like start working out do it try
to put some [ __ ] muscle on because
I've never had muscle my entire [ __ ]
life so I maybe like you know sound like
oh I got all this free time but like
maybe after the tour
like I got money and just tiresome
[ __ ] to be like just do it three
days a week yeah
it gets your endorphins going and stuff
so I also don't want to become like hey
[ __ ] jacked and [ __ ] no but even just
a little bit I bet if you felt I I don't
want to get like Chappelle not like I'm
like [ __ ] Hill Chappelle but like
he's very big like remember Chappelle
was like just [ __ ] like you like in
fact like [ __ ] like not even like you
you were more Jack than Chappelle now
Chappelle is [ __ ] jacked oh I haven't
seen him what do you mean he's been
working oh for Years bro like now you
seem to especially takes his [ __ ]
shirt off and he's like like really I
didn't know that yeah like he looks like
a [ __ ] male model yeah um but they're
not even like oh it's all trip the arms
are huge it's a gun show which is so
funny too because you I think of them
like yeah
but like you know it's like that's the
idea it's like people can change and
[ __ ] yeah maybe it's possible
that like if I've done this far maybe I
can [ __ ] start building some goddamn
muscle [ __ ] yeah I like it muscle Muse
there you go muscle Muse yeah muscles
your muscles
um spell it like the fish though like
the piss clam muscles mute oh [ __ ] yeah
muscle blow blow Blowfish Muse I was
thinking Blowfish right because they
[ __ ] I don't know I think there's so
many options out there but I feel like
we're gonna find one that that's gonna
be good so
um and again the good thing is we could
talk about that and then again there's
tons this is only our second one and I
feel like when we start getting in the
groove there's so many stories like the
one I said about Logan earlier that
happens that again is like to me it's
it says choices I have to make where I'm
like
again it's like okay for four weeks
she's been going to school she gets up
and goes to school at like 8 30 gets
then she has study hall and or like
chess she's doing chess
um yes on Mondays they're teaching her
chess let me can I can I just point out
that this kid
is already very strategic yeah if you
guys teach her chess you're [ __ ] I
know because she's going to be moving
you two around that house like [ __ ]
pieces on a goddamn board man she's
clever she I've said like she's smart
like her mother and crafty like her
father no she's it's somebody but she
well literally like so I I'd bring her
to the park right and someday there's
been a couple times we go to the park we
scoot
um we rollerblade we do sidewalk chalk
sometimes we would be gone we would go
and we would do that and she'd be like
I'm tired and I'm like but we've only
been gone like 30 minutes I'm like let's
just hang out a little bit longer and
skate
and they get her to skate I would sort
of be like well look let's take a couple
videos pictures so we can send them to
Mommy and that would get her going I
said if you do that then we could sit in
the car right and we'll watch like uh
you know an episode of trolls or a
cartoon or something on my on my
dashboard
um so then she tells Jordan the other
night like literally this happened like
because now we move so we don't live by
that Park so I haven't done that in
about six months so just last night or
two nights ago she was mommy remember
when we used to go to the park and skate
she's a kid then you love like now we
get to use a sidewalk chalk so sorry
that's how it started Jordan goes hey we
have a sidewalk and now it's safe you
can literally sit on our sidewalk and
use sidewalk chalk like you used to do
at the park excuse mommy when we used to
go to the park and daddy you know we
take pictures of us and drawing a
sidewalk truck and she'd be like Daddy
like look what Logan Drew and send the
picture she's like I never drew that
daddy used to draw that with this with
the sidewalker and [ __ ] drop down oh
yeah six months later bro like listen
like really like trying to pit us
against each other dude it's crazy she's
very like and you're gonna let her play
chess we gotta I I mean yes but I think
you guys are [ __ ] now your pawns I
know it's she but she
again
what was the game what did she get out
of that drop and dime on you 60. I don't
know I feel like she wants to uh she
doesn't want she doesn't want to like
hold something back but I also think she
then Jordan will be like a little bummed
at me and then maybe her and I will Tip
Tap back and forth and then like oh but
come on Logan Let's Take a Ride let's
let's spin them I don't know if she's
trying to be like look J Daddy's paying
too much attention to Mommy so let me
put him let him me pit them against each
other do you know what a kid like that a
kid like that grows up to be like I have
a weather machine pointed at Australia
I'll take 40 billion dollars or every
Australian dies
that's a [ __ ] Super Genius right
there no she I I she's funny but again
the thing the good thing is I don't feel
like these things that like just like
with the kid at school I don't feel like
they're coming from a malicious place as
much as like uh hey let me see what I
can get out of it yes which is yeah to
be fair a malicious place would be
horrible yeah but this is more like
let me see if I can play these humans
Yeah well yeah I guess
yes
she's a knight she don't see you as a
rookie you're all Bond sir no
um well everyone's in for a [ __ ]
sweet surprise man sweet surprise not
really surprised everyone's in for a
neat treat neat treat Jesus Christ This
is a dad podcast you're gonna have some
[ __ ] metal ass good times in the next
episode because
the little princess herself Logan
is going to be here to tell you how she
feels about
her impending brother perhaps the name
that she wants to give the kid yay and
all the politics of Logan Lee Muse world
man our first guest
on Father's Day
um will be Logan yeah Jay's dog next
week
on Father's Day
um there it is kids you're episode two
you're like you know all right episode
one was promising what did they do in
episode two oh they told us the sex of
the baby what will they do in episode
three
you'll meet the other kid yeah and she
chatty and funny oh yeah
um and you'll you'll hear girl Muse for
the first time
and you'll be like oh my God we can get
her to say [ __ ] like snoo snoo yeah
she'll be I think she'll be fine if
she's so she warms up she's gonna be
especially I'll put the headphones on
her she'll be like oh I hear my own
voice oh yeah
um there it is kids there's your your
second episode man
that's uh a look at uh you know [ __ ]
born to be dead
[Music]
running down the highway
I'm chasing my daughter
or do we keep it or give him Wizards
leave
um so many questions upon her so many
weeks until the baby was born where is
she right now uh she said she putting
Logan in the bed oh months she is uh
she's at our house yeah okay probably in
my bed so wait I'm sorry I think uh so
next Monday we go for that scan I
believe which would be 20 weeks so next
Monday she'll be uh so she's 19 weeks oh
I've been out on tour of course with the
clerks through the convenience tour
where 20 shows in to a 50 Show run so
I've got I'm not even the halfway mark
but I left a month ago and you know we
went to the premiere and and I you know
I knew Jordan was pregnant but you
couldn't really tell no
um but I saw her today and yeah oh yeah
it's got a big old [ __ ] baby in her
yeah yeah
um it's very exciting and it's very
so because again we tried so and again
we'll talk more about that but about how
you tried that's the sexy part I would
put my wiener in there and I would hump
until I came and then yeah because I
know I know we were talking about we
started with we started talking about it
and then we veered off I think because I
told the story but I'm saying like the
cool thing is that you know we talked
about it we got like that we pissed on
sticks
um and like it happened in like you know
it happened like four months and that's
the name of the episode by the way
pissed on sticks yes yes
um he'll have to pray he might have to
put will use two dollar signs for the
S's and pissed yeah that way [ __ ]
the government Apple they can't show us
no no they're being dirty yeah and
they're like oh they're being hip
on the sticks with dollar signs
use the dollar signs on this on the S on
the sticks as well oh yeah oh hockey
sticks
[Laughter]
I was thinking double hockey sticks
uh there it is kids uh for Father's Day
I'm Kevin Smith Jason you uh Happy
Father's Day everybody
[Music]
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]